however you and youate for that matter
we defended your called it to now the
Shar calls us to put you in your place
there is an Islamic crime problem within
the UK this is an objective fact oh is
it okay this should outrage Muslims
instead Muslims rush to deny the issue
or defend the perpetrators do you equate
that to Christianity to Judaism no you
don't so can you please tell me what has
groomers these groomers or any of them
what connection correlation causation do
they have with Islam please tell me I
want to know before you jump on this
islamist thing every two seconds yeah
please bring me your
evidence just imagine the people back in
the day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on that you read it wherever you
was brothers and sisters and dear
friends the Shar brothers and sisters
calls us to always defend the honor of
any Muslim whoever it is for that matter
if they are being accused of something
if they make mistakes we should always
assume the best that's what we know from
the salaf that they tell us that if you
want to see your brother's beard dren
drenched in alcohol you should assume
that somebody ped it over them if you
hear one of your Muslim Brothers on a
mountain saying I am your lord and you
are my servant you should assume that
he's reading the verse of the Quran so
there is many excuses to be made when it
should be but when the time comes when
you're like all lines have been crossed
all lines when an individual like Andrew
Tate who his brother and if I'm not
mistaken himself as well are donating
towards a filthy dirt scumbag dirt bag
like Tommy Robinson who is the reason
why Muslims are being massacred the man
who committed those acts of killing 51
plus people in New Zealand and wrote RAM
on it because of their uh propaganda
that this is somehow related to Muslims
Andrew Tate has on his blood in his hand
he does and many like him we need to
start questioning him and saying hold on
a second where is your allegiance to
where is your allegiance to because
there is a lot of things that we can
talk about we've been ignoring why we've
been assuming the best in you we've
defended you when it came to the
accusations of um the the whole court
cases against you when it came to
yourself you would deny that's the M
they're trying to take me out this that
you know don't look at this oh they're
making stuff up false Witnesses all this
kind of stuff okay and then we said yep
okay that's true and under Islamic La we
have a different system where we judge
if one is guilty or not with evidences
so we assume the best in you yes and
those cases those uh uh those cases were
dropped yes even not appealing the
opinion for that matter or whatever but
we assume the best in you then why is it
why is it that you when it comes to the
whole issue of grooming gangs or
whatever it is that has nothing to do
with Islam in any way shape or form you
keep repeating this islamist islamist
this islamist that Islam is this here is
Andrew say is saying there is an Islamic
crime problem within the UK this is an
objective fact oh is it okay this should
outrage Muslims instead Muslims rush to
deny the issue or defend the
perpetrators rape is illegal in Islamic
countries punishable by death as an
illegally as as is illegally invading
and occupying lands you can enter Qatar
or Bahrain you can't enter Qatar or
bahin illegally there is problems with
Islamic crime with which must be
accepted before it it is addressed there
is nothing that is worse for the
reputation of Islam than watching
Muslims defend child rapist and you
wonder why Islam is disliked in
Christian nations who the flipp in hell
has defended groomers can I ask you a
question what on Earth are you talking
about he even hijab even asked him a
question and he carries on saying I know
Muslims that say which Muslim or where
in Islam does it tell you as Muslim
you're Muslim yourself that we should be
okay with groomers what the hell are you
talking about what do you mean there is
an Islamic crime problem in the UK do
you say that to all the churches your
brother does your brother go and condemn
all the churches and connect all those
pedophiles who have been raping those
kids burying them bodies have been FAL
today all across Catholic churches yes
in churches is it a Christian problem
crime problem they have when there's
Jewish pedophiles in America running can
this or is exposed running to Israel for
Safe Haven do you come and say there is
a Jewish
crime problem why is it that when
there's groomers that have nothing to do
with Islam rather they live more of a
western lifestyle with their drugs
alcohol clubbing partying having sex
outside of marriage and Crossing all
boundaries when it comes to you know
taking advantage of these girls how the
hell what's that to do with Islam do you
equate that to the Christianity to
Judaism no you don't so can you please
tell me what has groomers these groomers
or any of them
what connection correlation causation do
they have with Islam please tell me I
want to know before you jump on this
islamist thing every two seconds yeah
please bring me your evidence anytime
something happens when the Southport
attacks happened you did the same thing
when the attacks in Germany happened you
did the same thing who are you the
question we're going to ask now is we
have to who are you being paid by Who's
got what on you because this what it's
starting to sound like what are you on
about I'm I'm starting to think like are
you on drugs what is it is someone
paying you what is I'm going to I'm
going to speculate speculate all kind of
things because this reminds me of when
the Battle of tabuk happened and among
the maaf many of those maaf Hypocrites
amongst them three Believers Believers
did not attend the battle and they were
severely boycotted now these Believers
obviously they were three of them
wasb
Malik and
B these were the three companions who
were who their loyalty was tested in
different battles in the Battle of B bad
in the Battle of in the Battle of KHAK
in different places their loyalty
Allegiance was clear to the Muslims it
was clear but in this battle they
refrained from coming and they had no
excuse not to come but guess what they
were
booted even though Muslims knew they are
believers they proved their Allegient
they fought in battles yes okay number
one they they did all that I've never
seen you like rarely defend Islam or
anything for that matter okay so I don't
know what games you're playing so these
individuals were severely boycotted so
much so Allah says in the
Quran in Surah Toba and Allah has
forgiven the three these were after they
were boycotted Allah has forgiven the
three whose whose case had been put off
when the Earth with all its vastness
seemed to have become narrow for them
and their own Souls were a burden on
them and they realized that there was no
refuge for them except in the mercy of
Allah himself Allah turned them with
kind Allah turned them with kindness so
that they should turn to him surely he's
forgiven and compassionate okay in your
case we look at sneo sneo has shown he's
serious about his religion sneo has
shown to us yes that he wants to learn
sneo in certain situations he's like
listen Islam all day every day sneo has
shown his H ility to the enemies of
Islam like Tommy Robinson he not
refuting him yes he's shown sne is not
perfect however you Andre Tate for that
matter we defended your honor because
Shar called it to now the Shar calls us
to put you in your place you need to
know your place you are here doing
nothing but your rhetoric the things
that you say is causing our brothers and
sisters who are walking down the road to
be attacked and killed for that matter
because of your stupidity okay I don't
know what is it that you want I don't
know if you know they gave give you a
deal you know we'll drop the charges and
you know we need you to turn against
Islam I don't know I'll be honest with
all things anything goes to my mind I'll
be honest with you here I even doubt I
even think to myself are you like really
really do you really believe in Islam
the only thing that I have that defense
is that Allah says in the Quran to the
bedin they say we've come to believe no
Allah says you have not believed rather
You' have submitted I think you are
still at the stage of submission which
is you just accept Islam and its basic
principles Etc you have not become a
Believer yet yes A True True Believer
because I've never seen you for example
pray not I'm seen you do in your private
life okay um you still do your certain
lifestyle whatever is for that matter
you Haven shown us no actions like sneo
to your faith there has not been actions
where we can say hold on a second this
guy is serious you have never ever and
you don't need to come to our circles
you have never gone to reached out to
the per people around you Etc who is for
that matter and we don't know nothing
I'll be honest with you there is nothing
so there is a big question on Mark on
you yeah I'm not going to come say
you're a spy yeah for nio we can say
definitely he's not a spy definitely
he's not a hypocrite most certainly he's
a Muslim would somebody even come and
say that he's even a believer he's got
faith in him now yeah with yourself we
can't say you're a spy we cannot say
you're a mafic a hypocrite who
pretending to be a Muslim we don't have
evidence for that because somebody who
comes to Islam with certainty we can
only take him out with certainty so we
don't have that certainty just yet and
not that we're looking for it but
there's big question marks on this
matter and every Muslim should boycott
you or put pressure on you because you
are basically donating to Tommy Robinson
£30,000 if I insulted your mom if I
insulted your dad and um uh somebody
donated how would you feel how would you
feel tell me as a Muslim we defended
your honor when all these accusation
were made towards you you cannot even
defend the honor of your own religion
and you're throwing it under the bus I
don't know why I don't know why I don't
know if they have a leverage over you I
don't know if what it is I don't know
but let me tell you something there is a
big fat question mark on your head from
now on yeah and we will put that
pressure on you again and again and
again and I ask Muslims to put that full
pressure on him yes we will TR truly see
what he's about very soon yes we will
truly see what he's about really soon
inshallah yeah in the meantime brothers
and sisters like I said before what he
said about gender ET there was lot of
Truth he spoken we're not negating him
for that but however when it comes to
this matter of our religion our religion
comes before anything and let me tell
you something Andrew you might be
watching this video Islam don't need you
not even this bit we don't need you
Allah uses if you have ill intentions if
you got wrong intentions Allah will use
you with your plans that you're making
if you are making plans against his
religion Allah will use you to bring
more people to Islam Allah does not need
you bear that in mind very carefully and
when you support people like Tommy
Robinson the flipping dirt B who have
confronted face to face that little
intellectual intellect physical
yes that little flipping clown who has
no idea what he's talking about okay he
does not care about the victims he
rather cares about who the perpetrators
are flipping sick or you're as sick as
him so I'm going to say inshallah
brothers and sisters be very very wary
of this guy he's treading on th ice he's
treading on fin ice inah and let's see
how things take uh let's see how things
take shape in in the coming months or
years inshallah and we are going to see
for that matter till next time brother
and sister inshallah I want to say that
look again I'm not praising anyone or
dis praising anyone for that matter dis
praising and but at least he has shown
his loyalty to his religion he's shown
it and this is what our religion
requires that you put Islam first before
your brother or whoever for that matter
who is a Christian or whatever your
religion comes first if you are going to
take your religion and put it under the
bus before anything else there's a big
question mark on you that's a message to
Andrew Tate and I even challenge him not
that he needs me in a private discussion
before he thinks I'm doing it for public
views whatever in a private setting all
these accusations and things that is
thrown around I challenge him for a
debate I challenge him yes and I'm sure
there's you know aldah people who are
much much more senior than myself like
Muhammad hijab who will do a better
jobah all day every day but someone like
me I would even debate you no problem at
all till next time